you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is round ten
from the 2013 World Chess Championship
match between a 9 and Carlsen going into
this round Carlson has a 6 to 3 lead
over none and Carlsen with the white
pieces in this one opened with e4 and
for the first time in the match we get
to see the Sicilian defense keep in mind
Carlsen needs only a draw or win in
order to become world champion it is a
race again to six and a half points and
we see the Rasul emo Knight blocks and
as they follow up d4 if you're looking
for a fairly quiet system in reply to
the Sicilian it should be five line
might be something to look into
Karlsson at this stage in the match not
wanting to complicate the position too
much so we have this exchange as soon as
the bishop is questioned white gives it
up but has at least inserted c4 so that
there is going to be control over the
two potential pawn breaks d5 and b5 and
we'll see a lot of emphasis placed on
controlling these squares from here on
out so first Knight f6 Bishop g5 you may
not think there's too much difference
between these two moves at this moment
but there certainly is by keeping
pressure on the knight there's not time
to fee and kettle the bishop
successfully because you can take the
night off damage the structure and this
night would be granted a beautiful home
on d5 but if you were to bring your
night out well now there's time for
black to maybe consider this but it's
Bishop g5 and so the bishop has to go
elsewhere Knight c3 it should be seven
castles Bishop c6 putting pressure on e4
and this is a quite common maneuver out
of this variation to drop the Queen back
there's a few reasons behind that one it
vacates the d4 square for the knight or
I could grab the bishop and it's still
keeping a close eye on the two potential
pawn breaks d5 and b5 black castles sure
enough the knight posts in the center
reinforces the structure with b3 and now
we grab that bishop
and we play our rope to see one this
might be tempting as well it's a
half-open file but it doesn't address
this potential pawn break if we're kind
F to d1 we have B five and you can't
take because you would drop the night so
we need to first secure our night
position our night position so b5 is no
longer a good idea just win upon maybe
there's even something sneaky ER so we
don't do that b5 is not allowed Bishop
has a question truncheon to it this is
also a flight square Knight to d7
there's two possibilities for this
Knight now b6 isn't really doing
anything but tying down the Queen to its
defense better better post for the
bishop hard Square to argue with and
very well centralized and pointing right
at g7 there could maybe one day be
another piece converging on that g7
point so finally the last rook gets
involved four black little flight square
four white and this Queen is retreating
to only take up a better post she
eventually wants to break the fifth rank
all the white rooks are working for
white now and with Queen to d2 there is
this common night pivot that is
available exploiting the Queen's
unprotected nature notice how if b5
there could be Knight d5 there's no time
to take the knight the Queen the Queen's
are in tension Queen on a5 is
unprotected if you take the Queen you
don't take back right away you take the
piece width check and only then take the
Queen back and then white is doing quite
well reinforcing c4 the one thing you'd
really don't want to happen
structure-wise on the Queen side for
white is this sort of thing where
they're split but clearly in this
variation the rooks are well positioned
to keep the structure as is an a/b
structure so we don't have that but that
is the idea that is in mind after Queen
d2 and the King gets out of it King to
f8 so that Knight d5 isn't available
Queen takes Queen well you can't take a
piece now with check the King
f8 so King f8 it is Queen the b2 and
there might be some issue on this g7
square well the King comes back and
during the livestream I had thought that
maybe would have some repetition the
Queen going back and forth the King
going back and forth but certainly Anand
is looking for more it may seem like
this is appealing to take that pawn and
then land a discovered check but it's
just not working out black at the end of
it is up a piece so what did we have
we had a for clamping down on this b5
advance going to h5 Knight to e2 two
possibilities for the knight - maybe
harass the black Queen Bishop f6 and now
at this point now that the bishops are
in tension with one another
as soon as he's no longer around to
watch over d6 well you're going to have
a lot of pressure being placed on that
point he's a number one defender of the
d6 pawn so he is challenged right away
he's recaptured as otherwise you would
be dropping the rook you need to take
the rook you need to take with the rook
and after Queen to e5 the idea will be
to eventually question the Queen's
position first piling up on d6 Knight f6
is there there's pressure Nani for that
is defended and there is also no thought
of d5 the Queen would be hit and so what
gets played after rookie 3 we have rook
d7 and now a very clamping down type of
move a5 you can forget about playing b5
Queen is there to support keep in mind
and now we have after Queen g5 an
evaluation shift what's maybe better and
this is a computer recommendation is g5
to secure this Queen position but
instead in the game after a five it was
Queen g5 which now allows 'if I've
breaking open the position hitting at
these two points the knight has to run
in reverse in order to defend these six
now in the game we had pawn takes pawn
but what was available was also Knight
g3 or maybe even Knight c3 with ideas of
hitting the Queen and then also
converging on d6 however what was chosen
is the immediate capture and this pawn
new
needs to be tracked down right away if
something like b4 c5 is allowed and that
pun is defended with that sort of
structure well it's going to be game
over for black so it's rook c6 f4 first
and we're going down a line now where
we're going to have all major pieces
exchanged and we're going to enter a
knight King and pawn endgame alone so f4
is first inserted the queen needs to
drop back to corral the pawn on d6 and
we have everything trained on this point
and sure enough all major pieces coming
off the board and it was important by
the way in all of those cases that the
knight would be the last one to capture
as otherwise there are moments where c5
can be played exploiting the pin on the
D file so that's why we have that exact
order coming about in the knight being
the last one to recapture and now in
this endgame the idea is to get the King
more active and very active is this
white King what these next moves making
a beeline right for the beep on black is
there however just in the nick of time
to stop white from from putting pressure
on b7 so what follows is getting the
knight to a better post an even better
post on e4 looking at the d6 square
hitting at f7 also looking for some fork
maybe picking up the Jeep on 93 g3 a
question is thrown to the knight he does
run into d6 and after G 5 we give a
check and another check and now this is
where there was a big thing for Carlsen
having about 61 minutes remaining on his
clock he invests a good chunk of that
nearly a half hour spent on Knight g8
and you may wonder why so much time was
invested on such a move well look of
look at the variation that comes about
we're after takes takes King g7 the
knight he's trapped white is giving up
the knight in exchange for tracking down
these ponds and then having a footrace
literally a foot soldier race
to see who can queen first so he doesn't
just want to give himself up needs to
take somebody down with them he grabs
upon at least on f5 and then the King
hunts down the b-pawn whereas the knight
tracks down the F pawn and before you
know we have to passed pawns King b6 is
there clearing the way for the pun and
also shouldering off the night it's a
big race and at the end of it we have
both sides queening white Queens first
and then takes up a nice residence in
the center even without these pawns on
the board it's still a very difficult
win for black Queen and night versus
Queen should be a theoretical draw but
we have the game actually ending much
more roughly we keep in mind that you
can't at this point take the Ponda she
has to watch over the knight so what is
tried as a knight check King b5 like
takes on b3 the Queen now is able to
give a check and at this moment I was
able to notice that the game would be
ending very soon because by force it
would either be a perpetual check or the
Queen's would be exchanged and that
right there would secure a drop so what
was played is King to h6 King to h6 and
what was the follow-up Queen b6 forcing
a queen exchange what else would there
have been to do going to one of these
squares well the Queen basically keeps
making use of these three squares
wherever the King goes you continually
give a check until he has to go well
it's either perpetual check or he ends
up somewhere on this sixth rank so what
was played as Queen c7 King h6 Queen b6
and the Queen's are exchanged and with
that well the games finishes up like
this with the pawns being captured and
at this moment right here we go all the
way down to move 65 Knight takes pawn
and it is at this point it is of course
a draw no side can win and with that the
World Chess Championship title goes to
mag
miss Carlson so congratulations to him
I've covered all games now it feels good
to be done and I hope you enjoyed tuning
in for this maybe this is the first
video you're watching but I covered all
of these games all 10 games of this
match and at the end of this video I'll
include a playlist so you can check them
out if you missed any of them so thank
you for tuning in thank you for your
support as well and I hope you enjoyed
this World Chess Championship match and
again congratulations to Magnus Carlsen
that's all for this video take care bye
you